At the beginning of this lecture, we consider
the problem of why if I hold a sheet of paper
up in front of the scene, I do not see an
image on that sheet of paper. And the reason
for that as we talked about was that at any
particular point on the paper, we record the
total amount of light that's falling on that
particular point and that light has come from
very, very many points in the real world itself.
We've recorded the total amount of light there.
We didn't say anything about the direction
that the light rays came from.
So, what if we could actually record at each
point not just the amount of light but the
direction that the light came from? This gets
us into the area of what's called a light
field. Now, a light field is, mathematically,
it's a function that describes the light that's
travelling in every single direction at every
single point in space.
Think about the room that you're in at the
moment. Consider any particular point in that
room and there'll be a large number of light
rays passing through that point and they will
have come from many many other points within
the room.
So, very, very complex lots of light rays,
all going different directions and coming
from different places.
So, a light field sensor attempts to capture
some of that, to capture the color, the intensity
and the vector direction of all these rays
of light. Traditional camera simply adds up
all the rays of light and records the sum
total. Light field cameras try to record the
directions as well and the direction is really
important. Consider this example again of
the thin lens model. We have an object in
the world. It's a whole bunch of light rays
leaving the object passing through the lens
and passing through the focal plane.
I've shown here a pixel and the light rays
that are entering that pixel are coming from
a large number of different directions. Let’s
animate this, you can see that the object
is moving and we can see the light rays from the tip of that object moving across the array of pixels.
So, the object when it's really close to the
lens would be well out of focus in the traditional
camera. What's happening though is that those
light rays are now following across a range
of pixels and that each pixel, those light
rays are entering at a different angle.
So, if those pixels were able to record not
just the amount of light but the direction
at which they are coming from as well, it
would be possible to compute the image even
though it is very, very out of focus and this
is a technology that's starting to emerge
now in what's called light field cameras.
Now, one of the first on the market, the consumer
level of light field cameras, this one produced
by Light Row and in the right hand side of
this slide, what we can see is the light field
image being post-processed to bring a particular part of the image into focus. So, the person
is clicking on a particular point in the image
and using all the raw information from the
light field, the amount of light and its direction,
we can compute the appropriate in focus image.
We cant let every point in the image in focus
at all the time but we can now select after
we took the picture which part we would like
to have in focus and that's a big step forward.
Early versions of light field cameras, the
research versions of these were very very
massive arrays of cameras, very expensive
and far from portable. Here's an example of
an early portable light field camera. Again,
an array of cameras, which are trying to capture
the light rays coming from the world and the
various directions at which they've come from.
This is a technology now, which is becoming
quite accessible as the cost of phones is
being reduced. It's now possible to create
enormous arrays of cameras and these videos
show some work that's being done using commodity
mobile phone cameras, cheap digital cameras
in order to be able to capture light fields
and once you have a captured light field then,
you can perform some very amazing visual effects,
stop motion effects and so on.